welcome to this video coverage for round
three of the candidates and cantonments
the scale we have mamedyarov playing
island and yeah the tournament the short
tournament for both players so far
couldn't have been any more different
well island had an excellent start by
beating Aronian in round 1 playing a
draw in the second round Mammadyarov
really AM started badly he let some
chances slide chances slip in round one
against Apollo and then just lost and
round two against Aronian yeah with in
almost yeah was something that you
almost could call blundering the Queen
yeah not not 21 mover but yeah certainly
very disappointing performance for the
player from other by John so let's see
what happened in this game the Slav
defense again from are not just yet
again maybe the wrong the wrong
expression but he offered his love
yesterday against to par love so well
this seems to be in his some Yanez
preparation for this tournament
Mammadyarov plays Quincy too young he
had played in round one night BTW two
against Apollo and now he goes form in
quincy tube yeah it's in fact one of the
less common lines Quincy to but it's in
fact one of those lines that are ya not
the mainland but they they have they
contain some poison so black needs to be
precise unhook played Bishop g4 yeah
this is some may be the main line
nowadays and
um maybe even know that I'm producing a
video series on openings for the
internet chess club the ICC where I am I
do that in German language this needs to
be said where I introduce a repertoire
based on the Slav and for this repeater
I have also chosen this line so I know
some details about it because I did some
research on it only recently among the
general of now played Ned Beatty to this
is the more galets a solid way to play
the sharp way to place Knight c3 which
intends to build up quickly this huge
center this line or ever um yeah has
that has a slight slight problem and
this is because of night bd7 before and
now the new or let's say not yet really
a recognized mini 5 and this is a
two-item funny quite a little story when
I did the research for my video series
about two weeks ago I found that this
move was only played twice in the whole
database while Bishop takes f3 was
played like I know dozens of times and I
was I'm sorry this was too much let's go
back and I was wondering what did the
big problem with e5 was and I only had
two games with it and I analyzed a bit
and didn't find anything for white in
fact I I thought that the black is
really comfortable here and yeah I
presented my lines just a couple of
lights a quick video for the asus eee
and then only one week later a couple of
days ago I got a new chess book in the
mail the classical sloth by grand master
Boris of rook and yeah he had exactly
the same lines at his book he also he
wrote the same story that I told on
video
yeah I found only two games why's that
isn't this a good move and then he
showed his analysis was that was almost
identical to mine which is yeah no no
special thing because what people use
the same engines and they come to the
same conclusions normally so yeah this
is a good line and maybe this is why
Mammadyarov went for night BD to this is
not bad of course the idea is to
overprotect this night and allow this
fianchetto white couldn't fianchetto
without this because oh this just looks
too ugly this structure with this
isolated porn at the double porn so
white prepares the development of the
bishop to g2 and this is what happened
97 g3 or very very normal yeah now he
played 95 and I'm not sure that I like
this move really um it's not like a big
mistake or anything but I don't think
that it really leads to do anything
tangible for white I actually thought
that the best try for wide in this
position is to play like that and trying
to put some pressure on the beep on
black place Queen B 6 go for night see
for this was the the line that I
consider to be most critical or ever
after Queen a 60 this is better than the
capture black seems to be quite okay and
I still I felt that this is maybe the
area where Y term yeah like this for
example the white could search for and
learn something yeah this didn't happen
he played 95 Mammadyarov after Bishop h5
he took and castled now I'm not so sure
why 95 is such a great idea look at this
this was played
and now Alan played a five yeah the
thing is the night is not especially
great on b3 but yeah where do you put it
you can put it on f3 but it's not
particularly great there this is
possible good reply here what he wants
to do is he plays 93 and then wants to
push uniform just go for us and for a
big center and yeah now I think this is
very instructive how are not displaying
this played a 5 this is a very good and
important move it intends to play a 5 a
form gaining more space and then also
use a 5 as a square for the Queen to get
the rooks connected so if white ignores
everything here let's say players
Channing oops I'm sorry about that need
to wondering why this is impossible if
you would consider before here black has
a form you know and now this this is
very awkward where would you go white is
just very unharmonious Lee placed after
a five white basically only has one
month and this is a 4 yeah Bishop reform
is a nun's reply very logical move again
puts the bishop on this weekend Square
and intends to play Queen e7 connecting
looks and then according to
circumstances play one of the free moves
it will both be e 5 mostly here jump
lady for and now i'ma play d 5 and it
seems that at least according to my
database 'if I've here very normal
looking move is the first new move so
technically it's a it's a novelty in an
earlier game
in Istanbul 2012 must be the Olympiad I
guess only have the the location here
Queenie seminoles played between even
shock and vallejo bones after this moves
wide managed to get a big center with
therefore this was not the end of the
world but I feel Alan's move was just
more logically instantly goes 45 and
initiates play in the center yeah played
Bishop e3 captured and now on a plate
King edge a this is not a very self
evident move but if you look at it a bit
more detail you understand why this is
played he wants to play f6 and possibly
Bishop f7 you are giving a good retreat
square for the bishop on h5 and on mf7
it also good to pressurize the loose
night on v3 note that White's pieces are
loose the night is not protected by a
poem the queen is not protected by
anything and yeah well the bishop its
active in the center but it also subject
to a tech as we will see soon yeah King
edge 8 and now the next move by membered
yarrow I simply don't like it then you
played a five and I believe that this
instantly leads to good play for black
if you want to push in the center I
guess f4 is the better choice like this
f4f 6 and now my suggestion would be
something like that Bishop f2 to allow a
later night to deform and in this
position I guess we are talking about
yeah roughly equal chances but it's not
equal in terms of drawers it's a
complicated middle game where I guess
both players have the chances yeah he
played d5 and I simply don't like it
the next moves are almost forced you you
have a hard time to suggest any
alternatives and after them Black is
just better rook e8 was played attacking
e5 note that the bishops control the
central square C 1 as interim yeah let's
say the central posts for for the rooks
rookie one is not playable root g1s not
playable they are both controlled and
yeah after locate how do you keep the
pawn you only have one move f4 and after
f6 it turns out we have the same problem
again if I is attacked and white really
has no natural way to to cover it as
move flag rupee one yawa I'm going to
take it wide essentially must do that
and this means after night xf6 then this
only has activated black white has
played three pawn moves look at this 'if
I've f4 and captures in the process what
what happened he has weakened his king
by a form one of the moves that white
would love to play in this position
besides the fact that there's this
instant thread so you can even do that
but what you would love to do is to just
take your pawn move back it's just
weakening your position and here black
is already substantially better the
problem is that is also yeah this threat
simply how do you meet it play Bishop f3
and after now this capture and rookie
for like just has a number of very
convenient advantages he is nicely
centralized the rook is active you might
have night jumps and their king is just
re whites king it does not have a proper
palm protection anymore and
this also means that it is very very
tricky to play note that here on the
fourth-ranked this even this idea
available yeah why played rookie 3 after
the capture on a plate Queen to yet yeah
and a logical move again with the temple
intending to also use the rook soon now
should be 6 plate Queen h5 very very
logical looking at age two getting this
into the mix yeah went back to deform
using the bishop arrived defensive peace
bishop b6 was wasn't probably the best
possible move but wyd already is in
terrible shape rupee ate her intending
to quickly enter on the second-ranked
jung very tough white play droog f1 and
now night g force plate threatening on
edge to it turns out that instead of
rook f1 what White's needed to do to
keep up bit more resistance you need to
play a queen d three but even here black
has a strong reply can still go here
after this move how do you protect him
if you put if you play Quincy to for
example that's just 93 and this is
something that white is not going to
survive rookie to is just exceptionally
strong yeah I played rook f1 which isn't
the toughest defense but I guess it's
already
beyond beyond salvation yeah H to play
the Queen c2 to cover it and now c5 was
played a nice little technical stroke
highlighting that this Bishop does not
really have any great squares you go
here mm-hmm okay with a double attack do
here well checkmate okay III assaults
are not possible so you have to take it
took it with the night and now rook c8
is the key move it just puts this piece
into a deadly pin and white now what did
you try rookie one takes takes and now
just h6 simple chess getting a flight
square for the king some looked for the
king and it just intends to take c5 the
next move White has absolutely no way to
to keep it played this one and at the
same time I guess resigned at least
that's how it is in the official PGN
file yeah here after the king move Black
has many ways to to win the easiest is
probably nighty em with this idea and of
course it's just a very big Fork so a
win again for other who's leading the
tournament this size as much I can say
of course he let the tournament before
the round at least an shared first place
and with an additional Winnie will of
course still lead it with the plus 22
wins in the first three rounds this is
certainly an unexpected development
almont really wasn't one of the
favorites before the tournament but okay
he had a good start and
people with good starts in two events
always have chances so one an
uncertainty to be reckoned with um yeah
and for Mammadyarov basically this
tournament is over in terms of winning
it of course he never was one of the
heavy favorites I am had him as one of
my two dark horses yeah but always in my
texts I wrote yeah he needs a good start
maybe a quick the win in one of the
early rounds to to get to get get going
but exactly the opposite thing is
happening he lost two games and this
this game here was really a drastic loss
sort of a game where you feel that yeah
the white player something's not right
in the hole in the whole game yeah b5 is
simply a move that it's very very hard
to explain as the sequence is to totally
forced and it leads to an excellent
position for black end this is also very
easy to see if you'll give mommy dr of
this position you will just say okay
this is ugly but the thing is he played
e5 and after that there is no no way
back you have to play the moves that
that were put on the board f4f 6 and so
on it here White's defenses already yeah
super tricky
practical game so as mentioned good
start for Anand terrible one form my
McAuliffe I hope you enjoyed the
coverage and brief analysis of this game
and I'll be back on Monday with fourth
round coverage of the candidates thanks
for watching